comunicare comunicare deriva dal latino
comunicare ovvero rendere con divulgare
rendere noto e più comunicare è stata
un'esigenza sempre sentita dall uomo
singh ha condannato è infatti una forma
di comunicazione esperimento tra l'uomo
è stata la comunicazione verbale non ho
cercato di comunicare verbalmente ma
purtroppo non c'è riuscito non c'è
riuscito perché perché semplicemente
nella sua struttura ossea mancava l'osso
ioide l'osso ioide el'osso che noi
abbiamo sotto la lingua e che ci
permette di scandire i suoni quindi la
comunicazione avviene attraverso un
codice che viene decodificato un codice
come che viene decodificato e quindi
viene verificato un messaggio si è
sperimentata una nuova forma di
comunicazione con un codice comune e la
pro forma di comunicazione sperimentata
sono stati appunto i graffiti e grafite
appunto rappresentavano delle immagini
di vita quotidiana e quindi un codice
comune che era in grado di essere
decodificato e quindi noi adesso siamo
in grado tutti quanti di immaginare cosa
facessero i nostri antenati cosa devo
soliti fare quindi quale fosse la loro
giornata tipo quali fossero le loro
abitudini di caccia
la gestione appunto anche della propria
famiglia eccetera
in realtà gli uomini non sapevano che
stavano già scrivendo la loro storia con
i graffiti quindi molto legato al se
alla comunicazione appunto sono i segni
i semi che cosa sono solo una forma di
comunicazione elementare
c'è un qualcosa che sta per un
qualcos'altro quindi qualcosa che
decodifica un messaggio noi inculchiamo
l'importanza dei segni
sin da bambini ai nostri figli ai nostri
nipoti raccontandoli semplicemente la
fiaba di pollicino pollicino che fa
pollicino praticamente un giorno viene
abbandonato con i suoi fratelli nel
bosco da suo padre perché a calcio e
miseria e quindi sognava un futuro
migliore per i suoi figli
pulcino però si rende conto che
effettivamente vivere in una serata o
più serate in un bosco da bambini non è
proprio una situazione felice insomma è
sicura quindi che cosa fa semina durante
il tragitto casa a bosco dei sassolini
al ritorno quindi una volta nel bosco
con i suoi fratelli decide di seguire il
segno dei sassolini che comunicavano il
sentiero di ritorno a casa e quindi la
salvezza dunque non ricorderà i passi
che hai fatto nel camino mai sassolini
che ha lasciato è effettivamente però
nel tempo i sassolini si sono evoluti si
sono evoluti grazie alla tecnologia e
sono diventati digital signage ovvero
dei segnali digitali come il
videoproiettore e gli schermi che
utilizziamo tutti i giorni ovvero il
carmine nostri smartphone delle tv ho
ancora dei pc o dei cartelloni digitali
e quindi siamo passati da un'evoluzione
del segno che è diventato digital
signage un altro concetto molto legato
alla comunicazione è il marketing che ha
parlato per primo di marketing in italia
è stato il dottor pallavicini che
appunto il noto economista italiano che
negli anni cinquanta sessanta ha
definito il marketing come l'arte di
individuare creare e fornire valore per
raggiungere una determinata clienti hera
per soddisfare una determinata clientela
il marketing ha dovuto subire delle
variazioni anche nel corso del tempo
grazie sempre alla rivoluzione
tecnologica ovvero all'introduzione
della youth l'internet of things cioè
tutti noi oggi siamo in grado di essere
sempre connessi grazie ai nostri oggetti
che sono dotati di connessione appunto
c'è stata l'introduzione dei pico e del
bluetooth e wifi che ci permette di
avere una rete sempre con massa siamo
perennemente connessi quindi anche qui
abbiamo una rivoluzione nel marketing ha
una sua evoluzione quasi naturale dove
dal marketing si passa al proximity
marketing
un'evoluzione che noi possiamo notare e
possiamo respirare toccare vedere è
quella di matera matera da capitale
della vergogna è diventata patrimonio
dell'unesco e non solo matera è anche il
luogo di conservazione della prima forma
di comunicazione dell'uomo che sono
stati graffiti cioè noi né l'ipotesi
matera possiamo notare ancora i graffiti
alla base del mio progetto di grafico
smart city ci sono due considerazioni
fatte ovvero un'evoluzione naturale del
lo strumento di comunicazione dei
graffiti che vogliamo far diventare i
graffiti digitali e ancora il fatto che
materia sia stata scelta come città che
può sperimentare il 5 g e quindi con la
sua storia ultramillenaria poi insegnare
a tutte le città del mondo come essere
una smart city quindi matera non è
solamente sassi non è solamente
collegabile al al concetto di presepe ma
diventa un vero esempio di smart city
quindi il nostro progetto grafico
smaltite appunto nasce da un esperimento
che abbiamo effettuato a milano vicino
via tortona che il centro del design
mondiale e abbiamo individuato un luogo
c'è un luogo privo di significato che
porta a genova allora non solo lo
abbiamo reso luogo ma lo abbiamo reso un
luogo di aggregazione con la nostra
installazione cioè abbiamo convinto uno
dei più influenti e più importanti
designer internazionali karim rashid a
effettuare una a progettare un'opera su
questo muro che non solo ha progettato
ma anche firmato con la tecnica del
mosaico digitale e abbiamo usato il muro
quindi di una bellezza estetica tale da
diventare scenario di molteplici selphy
e quindi essere un
un muro insomma viale ma non solo
l'avevo dotati di tecnologia qui abbiamo
fatto parlare il muro ce l'abbiamo
dotato di un hippy con capace di
intercettare i device in prossimità
quindi permettendo loro la connessione
wifi un hotspot e di usufruire di una
marina di servizi quindi questo non
luogo è diventato una nuova piazza in
realtà stiamo partendo da matera 19
capitale della cultura per riqualificare
con la nostra infrastruttura urbana 11
zone periferiche di matera facendola
interpretare a undici artisti se da un
punto di vista grafico descrittivo
quindi da un punto di vista di
progettazione strutturazione l'opera
d'arte ma non solo anche da un punto di
vista tecnologico immersivo
esperienziale cioè appunto
approcciandosi semplicemente al muro si
potrà entrare a 360 gradi nel vivo
dell'opera d'arte
un altro poiché in progress che stiamo
attuando si chiama we are the smart è un
movimento artistico culturale che unisce
arte e tecnologia
infatti nella parola ultrà smart stressa
sì si può evincere la sempre esistita
appunto contaminazione tra arte e
tecnologia
uno dei primi sottoscrittori di die hard
smart del nostro movimento e oliviero
toscani che rappresenterà una delle
pareti di matera